SPEAKER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or to view
additional material from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK I want to review
a little bit what we said
about detection at the end of
last hour, last hour and a
half, because we were going
through it relatively quickly.
Detection is a very
funny subject.
Particularly the way that we
do it here because we go
through a bunch of very,
very simple steps.
Everything looks trivial--
I hope it looks trivial-- as
we go, at least after you
think about it for awhile, and
you work with it for awhile,
you will come back and look at
it and you will say, "yes, in
fact that is trivial." Nothing
when you look at it for the
first time is trivial.
And the kind of detection
problems that we're
interested in is--
to start out with-- we want to
look just at binary detection.
We're sending a binary signal,
it's going to go through some
signal encoder, which is the
kind of channel encoder we've
been thinking about.
It's going to go through a
baseband modulator, a baseband
to passband modulator.
It's going to have white
Gaussian noise, or some kind
of noise, added to it.
It's going to come out
the other end.
We come back from passband
to baseband.
We then go through a baseband
demodulator.
We then sample at that point.
And, the point is, when you're
all done with all of that,
what you've done is you've
started out sending either
plus a or minus a as a one-
dimensional numerical signal.
And when you're all through,
there's some one- dimensional
number that comes out, v. And
on the basis of that one-
dimensional number, v, you're
supposed to guess whether the
output is zero or one.
Now, one of the things that
we're doing right now is we're
simplifying the problem in the
sense that we're not looking
at a sequence of inputs coming
in, and we're not looking at a
sequence of outputs
coming out.
We're only looking at a single
input coming in.
In other words, you build this
piece of communication
equipment, you get it all tuned
up, you get it into
steady state.
You send one bit.
You receive something.
You try to guess at the
receiver, what was sent.
And at that point you tear the
whole thing down and you wait
a year until you've set
it up perfectly again.
You send another bit.
And we're not going to worry at
all about what happens with
the sequence, we're only
going to worry about
this one shot problem.
You sort of have some kind of
clue that if you send the
whole sequence of bits, in a
system like this, and you
don't have intersymbol
interference, and the noise is
white, so it's sort of
independent from time to time.
You sort of have a clue that
you're going to get the same
answer whether you send the
sequence of data or whether
you just send a single bit.
And we're going to show later
that that, in fact, is true.
But for the time being we want
to understand what's going on,
and to understand what's going
on we take this simplest
possible case where there's
only one bit that's being
transmitted.
It's the question, "Are we going
to destroy ourselves in
the next five years or not?" And
this question is important
to most of us, and at the output
we find out, in fact,
whether we're going to destroy
ourselves or not.
So it's one bit, but it's
one important bit.
OK, why are we doing
things this way?
Want to tell you a little story
about the first time I
really talked to
Claude Shannon.
I was a young member of the
faculty at that time, and I
was working on a problem
which I thought was
really a neat problem.
It was interesting
theoretically.
It was important practically.
And I thought, "gee, I finally
have something I can go to
this great man and talk to him
about." So I screwed up my
courage for about two days.
Finally I saw his door open and
him sitting there, so I
went in and started to tell
him about this problem.
He's a very kind person and he
listened very patiently.
And after about 15 minutes
he said, "My god!
I'm just sort of lost
with all of this.
There's so much stuff going
on in this problem.
Can't we simplify it a little
bit by throwing out this kind
of practical constraint you've
put on it?" I said, "yeah, I
guess so." So we threw that
out and the we went on for
awhile later, and then he
said, "My god, I'm still
terribly confused about
this whole thing.
Why don't we simplify it
in some other way?"
And this went on for
about an hour.
As I say, he was a
very patient guy.
And at the end of an hour I was
getting really depressed.
Because here was this beautiful
problem that I
thought was going to make me
famous, give me tenure, do all
these neat things.
And here he'd reduced
the thing to a
totally trivial toy problem.
And we looked at it.
And we said, yes this is
a trivial toy problem.
This is the answer.
The problem is solved.
But so what?
And then he suggested putting
some of those
constraints back in again.
And as we started putting the
constraints back in, one- by-
one, we saw that each time we
put a new constraint in--
since we understood the problem
and its simplest
form-- putting the constraint
in, it was still simple.
And by the time we built the
whole thing back up again, it
was clear what the answer was.
OK, in other words, what theory
means is really solving
these toy problems.
And solving the toy
problems first.
And in terms of practice, some
people think the most
practical thing is
to be practical.
And the whole point of this
course, and this particular
subject of detection is a
wonderful example of this, the
most practical thing is
to be theoretical.
I mean, you need to add practice
to the theory, but
the way you do things is you
start with a theory-- which
means you start with the toy
problems, you build up from
those toy problems, and after
you build up for awhile,
understanding what the practical
problem is also--
you then understand
how to deal with
the practical problem.
And the practical engineer who
doesn't have any of that
fundamental knowledge about
how to deal with these
problems is always submerged
in a sea of complexity.
Always doing simulations of
something that he doesn't, he
or she doesn't understand.
Always trying to interpret
something from it, but with
just too many things going on
to have any idea of what it
really means.
Ok, so that's why we're making
this trivial assumption here.
We're only putting one bit in.
We're ignoring what
happens all the
way through the system.
We only get one number out.
We're going to assume that this
one number here is either
plus or minus a, plus
the Gaussian
random noise variable.
And we're not quite sure why
it's going to be plus or minus
a, plus a Gaussian noise random
variable, but we're
going to assume that
for the time being.
OK?
So the detector observes the
sample values of the random
variable for which this is the
sample value, and then guesses
what the value of this random
variable, h, which is what we
call the input now.
Because we view it from the
standpoint of the detector--
the detector has two possible
hypotheses--
one is that a zero was
sent, and the other
that a one was sent.
And on the basis of this
observation, you take first
the hypothesis zero and you
say, "Is this a reasonable
hypothesis?" Then you look at
the hypothesis one, say, "Is
this a reasonable hypothesis?"
And then you guess whether you
think zero was more likely or
one is more likely, given this
observation that you've had.
So what they detector has,
at this point, is a full
statistical characterization
of the entire problem.
Mainly you have a model
of the problem.
You understand every probability
in the universe
that might have any
effect on this.
And what might have any
effect on this--
as far as the way we've
set up the problem--
is only the question of what
are the probabilities that
you're going to send
one or the other of
these signals here?
And conditional on each
of these, what are the
probabilities of this
random variable
appearing at the output?
Because you have to base your
decision only on this.
So all of the probabilities
only give you
this one simple thing.
Hypothesis testing, decision
making, decoding, all mean the
same thing.
They mean exactly
the same thing.
And they're just done
by different people.
OK, so what that says is we're
assuming the detector uses a
known probability model.
And in designing the detector,
you know what that
probability model is.
It might not be the right
probability model, and one of
the things that many people
interested in detection study
is the question of when you
think the probability model is
one thing and it's actually
something else, how well does
the detection work?
It's a little like the
Lempel-Ziv algorithm that we
studied earlier for doing
source coding.
Which is, how do you do source
coding when you don't know
what the probabilities are?
And we found the best way to
study that, of course, was to
first find out how to do source
encoding when you did
know what the probabilities
were.
So we're doing the
same thing here.
We assume the detector is
designed to maximize the
probability of guessing
correctly.
In other words, it's trying
to minimize the
probability of error.
We call that a MAP detector--
maximum a posteriori
probability decoding.
You can try to do
other things.
You can say that there's a cost
of one kind of error, and
there's another cost of
another kind of error.
I mean, if you're doing medical
testing or something.
If you guess wrong in one way,
you tell the patient there's
nothing wrong with them, the
patient goes out, drops dead
the next day.
And you don't care about that,
of course, but you care about
the fact that the patient is
going to sue the hospital for
100 million dollars and you're
going to lose your
job because of it.
So there's a big cost to
guessing wrong in that way.
But for now, we're not going
to bother about the costs.
One of the things that you'll
see when we get all done is
that putting in cost
doesn't make the
problem any harder, really.
You really wind up with the
same kind of problem.
OK, so h is the random
variable that will be
detected, and v is the
random variable
that's going to be observed.
The experiment is performed.
Some sample value of v is
observed, and some sample
value of the hypothesis
has actually happened.
In other words, what has
happened is you prepared the
whole system.
Then at the input end to the
whole system, the input to the
channel, somebody has chosen
a one or a zero without the
knowledge of the receiver.
That one or zero has been sent
through this whole system, the
receiver has observed some
output, v, so in fact we're
now dealing with the
sample values of
two different things.
The sample value of the input,
which is h, the sample value
of the output, which is v, and
in terms of the sample value
of the output, we're trying to
guess what the sample value of
the input is.
OK, an error then occurs if,
after the output chooses a
particular hypothesis as its
guess, and that hypothesis,
then, is a function of
what it receives.
In other words, after you
receive something, what the
detector has to do is somehow
map what gets received, which
is some number, into
either zero or one.
It's like what a
Quantizer does.
Mainly, it maps the whole
region into two
different sub- regions.
Some things are mapped into
zero, Some things
are mapped into one.
This H bar then becomes a random
variable, but is a
random variable that is a
function of what's received.
So we have one random variable,
H, which is what
actually happened.
There's another random variable,
H hat, which is what
the detector guesses
will happen.
This is an unusual random
variable, because it's not
determined ahead of time.
It's determined only in terms
of what you decide your
detection rule is going to be.
This is a random variable that
you have some control over.
These other random variables
you have no
control over at all.
So that's the random variable
we're going to choose.
And, in fact, what we're going
to do is we're going to say
what we want to do is this MAP
decoding, maximum a posteriori
probability decoding, where
we're trying to minimize the
probability of screwing up.
And we don't care whether we
make an error of one kind or
make an error of
the other kind.
OK, is that formulation of the
problem crystal clear?
Anybody have any questions
about it?
I mean, the easiest way to get
screwed up with detection is
at a certain point to be going
through, studying a detection
problem, and then you
suddenly realize you
don't understand what--
you don't understand what the
whole problem is about.
OK, let's assume we do know
what the problem is, then.
In principle it's simple.
Given a particular observed
value, what we're going to do
is we're going to calculate
the-- what we call the a
posteriori probability, the
probability given that
particular sample value
of the observation--
we're going to calculate the
probability that what went
into the system is a zero
and what went into
the system is a one.
OK?
This is the probability that
j is the sample value of H,
conditional on what
we observed.
OK, if you can calculate this
quantity, it tells you if I
decide that--
if I guess that H is equal to
j-- this in fact tells me that
this is the probability
that guess is correct.
And if this is the probability
that guess is correct, and I
want to maximize my probability
of guessing
correctly, what do I do?
Well, what I do is my MAP
rule is arg max of this
probability.
And "arg max" means instead
of trying to maximize this
instead of trying to maximize
this quantity over something,
what we're doing is trying to
find the value of j, which
maximizes this.
In other words, we calculate
this for each value of j, and
then we picked the j for which
this quantity is largest.
In other words, we maximize this
but we're not interested
in the maximum value of
it at this point.
We're interested in it later
because that's the probability
that we're choosing correctly.
What we're interested in, for
now, is what is the hypothesis
that we're going to guess.
OK?
So this probability of being
correct is going to the this
probability for this
maximal j.
And when we average over v we
get the overall probability of
being correct.
There's a theorem which is
stated in the notes, which is
one of the more trivial theorems
you can think of,
which says that if you do the
best thing for every sample
point you, in fact, have done
the best thing on average.
I think that's pretty clear.
If you, well I mean you can read
it if you want to form a
proof, but if you do the best
thing all the time, then it's
the overall best thing.
OK, so that's the general
idea of detection.
And in doing this we have to
be able to calculate these
probabilities, so that's
the only constraint.
These are probabilities, which
means that this set of
hypothesis is discrete.
If you have an uncountable
infinite number of hypotheses,
at that point you're dealing
with an estimation problem.
Because you don't have any
chance in hell of getting the
right answer, exactly
the right answer.
And therefore you have to
have some criterion for
how close you are.
And that's what's important
in estimation.
And here what's important is
really, do we guess right or
don't we guess right.
And we don't, we don't care.
There aren't any near
misses here.
You either get it on the
nose or you don't.
OK, so we want to study
binary detection now
to start off with.
We want to trivialize the
problem because even that
problem we just stated
is too hard.
So we're going to trivialize
it in two ways.
We're going to assume that there
are only two hypotheses.
That it's a binary detection
problem.
And we're also going to assume
that it's Gaussian noise.
And that will make it sort of
transparent what's happening.
So H takes the values
zero or one.
And we'll call the probabilities
with which it
takes those values
P zero and P one.
These are called a priori
probabilities.
In other words, these are the
probabilities that the
hypothesis takes to value zero
or one before seeing any
observation.
And the probabilities after you
see the observation are
called a posteriori
probabilities.
In other words, probabilities
after the observation and the
probabilities before
the observation.
Up until about 1950
statisticians used to argue
terribly about whether it was
valid to assume a priori
probabilities.
And as you can see by thinking
about it a little bit, the
problem they were facing was
they couldn't separate the
problem of choosing a
mathematical model and
analyzing it from the problem
of figuring out whether the
model was valid or not.
And at that point people
studying in that area had not
gotten to the point where they
could say, "Well, maybe I
ought to analyze the problem for
different models, and then
after I understand what happens
for different models I
then ought to go back because
I'll know what's important to
find out in the real problem."
But up until that time, there
was just fighting
among everyone.
Bayes was the person who decided
you really ought to
assume that there's a
model to start with.
And he developed most
of detection
theory at an early time.
And people used to think that
Bayes was a terrible fraud.
Because in fact he was using
models of the problem rather
than nothing.
But anyway, that's
where we were.
We're also going to assume that,
after we get all through
with modulation and
demodulation, and we really
want to look at a general
problem here.
There's one discrete random
variable, H, one analog random
variable, which has a
probability density, v, what
we want to assume is that
there's a probability density
that we know, which is the
probability density of the
observation conditional
on the hypothesis.
We're assuming that we know
this, and we know this--
we call these things
likelihoods--
and in most communication
problems anyway, it's far
easier to get your hand on these
likelihoods than it is
to get your hand the a
posteriori probabilities,
which you're really
interested in.
So we find these likelihoods,
we can find the marginal
density of the observation.
Which is just the
weighted sum.
The probability that the
hypothesis is zero times a
conditional probability of the
observation and so forth.
So we're going to assume that
those densities exist.
We're going to assume
that we know them.
And then with a great feat of
probability theory, we say the
a posteriori probability is
equal to the a priori
probability times the likelihood
divided by the
marginal probability of v. OK?
What was the first thing you
learn in probability when you
started studying random
variables?
It was probably this formula,
which says when you have a
joint density of two random
variables you can
write it in two ways.
You can either write, "density
of one times density of two
conditional and one is equal
to the density of two times
density of one conditional in
two." And then you think about
it a little bit and you say,
"A ha!" It doesn't matter
whether the first one is the
density or whether it's the
probability.
You can deal with it
in the same way.
And you get this formula,
which I hope is
not unusual to you.
OK, so our MAP decision rule
then, our MAP decision rule,
remember, is to pick the more,
is to find the a posteriori
probability which is
most probable.
Because that is the probability
of being correct.
So, in fact, if this probability
is bigger than
this probability, this is the a
posteriori probability that
H is equal to zero.
This is the a posteriori
probability that
H is equal to one.
So we're just going to compare
those two and pick the larger.
And if this one is larger than
this one, we pick our choice
equal zero.
And if it's smaller, we pick
our choice equal to one.
So this is what MAP
detection is.
Why did I make this greater
than or equal
and this less than?
Well, if we have densities,
it doesn't often make any
difference.
Strangely enough, it does
sometimes make a difference.
Because sometimes you can have
a density, and the densities
are the same for both of
these likelihoods.
And you can find situations
where it's important.
But when the two probabilities
are the same, the probability
of being correct is the same in
both cases, so it doesn't
make any difference what
you do when you
have a quality here.
And therefore we've just
made a decision.
We've said, OK, what we're going
to do is whenever this
is equal to this, we're
going to choose zero.
If you prefer choosing
one, be my guest.
All of your MAP error
probabilities will
be exactly the same.
Nothing will change.
It just is easier to do the
same thing all the time.
OK, well then we look at this
formula, and we say, "Well, I
can simplify this a little
bit." If I take this
likelihood and move it over to
this side, and if I take this
marginal density and move it
over to this side, and if I
take p zero and move it over
to this side, then the
marginal densities cancel out.
They had nothing to do
with the problem.
And I wind up with a ratio
of the likelihoods.
And what do you think
the ratio of the
likelihoods is called?
Somebody got the smart
idea of calling that
a likelihood ratio.
Somehow the people in statistics
were much better at
generating notation than the
people in communication theory
who have done just an abominable
job of choosing
notation for things.
But anyway, they call this
a likelihood ratio.
And the rule then becomes: if
the likelihood ratio is
greater than or equal to
the ratio of p1 to
p0, we choose zero.
And if it's less,
we choose one.
And we call this ratio
the threshold.
So in fact what this says is
binary MAP tests are always
threshold tests.
And by a threshold test I mean
finds the likelihood ratio,
compare the likelihood ratio
with the threshold-- the
threshold in fact is this
ratio of a priori
probabilities--
and at that point you
have actually
achieved the MAP test.
In other words, you have done
something which actually, for
real, minimizes the probability
of error.
Maximizes the probability
of being correct.
Well because of that, this thing
here, this likelihood
ratio, is called a sufficient
statistic.
And it's called a sufficient
statistic because you can do
math decoding just by
knowing this number.
OK?
In other words, it says you can
you can calculate these
likelihoods.
You can find the ratio of
them-- which is this
likelihood ratio-- and after you
know the likelihood ratio,
you don't have to worry about
these likelihoods anymore.
This is the only thing relevant
to the problem.
Now this doesn't seem to be a
huge saving, because here
we're dealing with two real
numbers-- well here we've
reduced it to one real number--
which is something.
When we start dealing with
vectors, when we start dealing
with wave forms, this is
really a big thing.
Because what you're
doing is reducing
the vectors to numbers.
And when you reduce accountibly
infinite
dimensional vector to a number,
that's a big advantage.
It also, in terms of the
communication problems we're
facing, breaks up a detector
into two pieces in an
interesting way.
Mainly it says there are things
you do with the wave
form in order to calculate what
this likelihood ratio is,
and then after you find the
likelihood ratio you just
forget about what the wave
form was and you
deal only with that.
What we're going to find out
is in this problem we were
looking at here--
we're going to find out
later when we look
at the vector problem--
in fact this thing here is in
fact the likelihood ratio if
you make an observation out
at this point here.
In other words, right at the
front end of the receiver,
that's where you have all
the information you
can possibly have.
If you calculate likelihood
ratios at that point what
you're going to do is to find
the likelihood ratio you're
going to go through all this
stuff right here and wind up
with that which is work which
is proportional to the
likelihood ratio right here.
OK, so one of the things we're
doing right now is we're not
looking at that problem.
We're only looking at the
simpler problem, assuming a
one dimensional problem.
But the reason we're looking
at it is that later we're
going to show that this is, in
fact, the solution to the more
general problem.
Which was Shannon's idea
in the first place.
Of, how do you solve the trivial
problem first and then
see what the complicated
problem is.
OK, so that's what we're trying
to do, summarized here
for any binary detection problem
where the observation
has a sample value of
a random something.
Namely, a random vector, a
random process, a random
variable, a complex variable,
a complex anything.
Anything whatsoever, so long
as you can assign a
probability density to it.
You calculate the likelihood
ratio, which is this ratio
here, so long as you have then
cities even talk about.
The MAP rule is to compare this
likelihood ratio with the
threshold data-- which is just
the ratio of the a priori
probabilities--
if this is greater
than or equal to
that, you choose zero.
Otherwise you choose one.
The MAP rule, as I said before,
partitions this
observation space
into two pieces.
Into two segments.
And one of those pieces
gets mapped into zero.
One of the pieces gets
mapped into one.
It's exactly like a
binary quanitizer.
Except the rule you use to
choose the the quantization
regions is different.
But a quanitizer maps a space
into a finite set of regions.
And this detection rule does
exactly the same thing.
And since the beginning of
information theory people have
been puzzling over how to make
use of the correspondence
between quanitization on one
hand and detection on the
other hand.
And there are some
correspondences but they
aren't all that good
most of the time.
OK, so you get an error when
the actual hypothesis that
occurred, namely the bit that
got sent was i and if the
observation landed in
the other subset.
We know that the MAP rule
minimizes the error
probability.
So you have a rule which you
can use for all binary
detection problems so long
as you have the density.
And if you don't have a density
you can generalize it
without too much trouble.
OK, so we want to look at the
problem in Gaussian noise.
In particular we want to
look at it for 2PAM.
In other words for a standard
PAM system, where zero gets
mapped into plus a and one
gets mapped into minus a.
This is often called antipodal
signaling because you're
sending a plus something
and a minus something.
They are at opposite ends
of the spectrum.
You push them as far away as you
can, because as you push
them further and further
away it requires
more and more energy.
So you use the energy
you have.
You get them as far apart as you
can, and you hope that's
going to help you.
And we'll see that
it does help you.
OK, so what you receive then,
we'll assume, is either plus
or minus a--
depending on which hypothesis
occured--
plus a Gaussian random
variable.
And here's where the notation
of communication theorists
rears its ugly head.
We call the variance of this
random variable n 0 over 2.
I would prefer to call
it sigma squared but
unfortunately you can't
fight city hall on
something like this.
And everybody talks about
n 0 and n 0 over 2.
And you got to get used to it.
So here's where we're starting
to get used to it.
So that's the variance of this
noise random variable.
OK, we're only going to send one
binary digit, H, so this
is the only, this is the sole
problem we have to deal with.
We've made a binary choice.
Added one Gaussian random
variable to it.
You observe the sum,
and you guess.
So what are these likelihoods
in this case?
Well, the likelihood if H is
equal zero, in other words if
you're sending a plus a, the
likelihood is just a Gaussian
density shifted over by a.
And if you're sending, on
the other hand, a one--
which means you're sending minus
a-- you have a Gaussian
density shifted over
the other way.
Let me show you a
picture of that.
We'll come back to analyze more
things about the picture
in a little bit, so don't
worry about most of the
picture at this point.
OK, this is the likelihood
probability density of the
output given that
you sent a zero.
Mainly that you sent plus a.
So we have a Gaussian density--
this bell shaped
curve-- centered
around plus a.
If you sent a one, you're
sending minus a-- one gets
mapped into minus a-- and you
have the same bell shaped
curve centered around minus a.
If you receive any particular
value of v, mainly suppose you
receive the value of v here,
you calculate these two
likelihoods.
One of them is this.
One of them is that.
You compare them, the ratio with
the threshold, and you
make your choice.
OK, so let's go back to do it.
To do the arithmetic.
Here are the two likelihoods.
You take the ratio of
these two things.
When you take the ratio
of them, what happens?
And this sort of always
happens in
these Gaussian problems.
These terms cancel out.
Well it always happens in these
additive Gaussian problems.
These terms cancel out.
You take a ratio of
two exponents.
You just get the difference.
So the likelihood ratio--
this divided by this--
is then e to the minus v minus
a squared over n0.
and v plus a squared over n0.
OK?
Because normally the Gaussian
density is something divided
by two sigma squared, and sigma
squared here is n0 over
2, so the 2's cancel out.
One nice thing about the
notation anyway, you get rid
of one factor of two in it.
Well so you have this
minus this.
When you take the difference
of these two things the v
squareds cancel out.
Because one of these things is
in the numerator, the other
one was in the denominator.
So you have this term
comes through as is.
This is--
you're dividing by this--
so when you multiply this
turns into a plus sign.
So the v squared here cancels
out with the v squared here.
The a squared here cancels out
with the a squared here.
And it's only the inner product
term that survives
this whole thing.
And here you have plus 2va.
Here you have plus 2va.
So you wind up with e to
the 4av divided by n0.
Which is very nice, because
what it says is this
likelihood, which is what
determines everything in the
world, is just a scalar in
multiple of the observation.
And that that's going to
simplify things a fair amount.
It's why that picture comes
out as simply is it does.
OK, so to do a little more
of the arithmetic.
This is the likelihood here,
e to the 4av over n0.
So our rule is you compare
this likelihood to the
threshold-- which is p1 over
p0, which we call eta--
and you look at that for awhile
and you say, "Gee, this
is going to be much easier
to deal with.
Instead of looking at the
likelihood ratio, I look at
the log likelihood ratio."
And people who deal with
Gaussian problems a lot, you
never hear them talk about
likelihood ratios, you always
hear them talk about log
likelihood ratios.
And you can find one from the
other, so either one is
equally good.
In other words, the log
likelihood ratio is a
sufficient statistic, because
you can calculate the
likelihood ratio from it.
So this is a sufficient
statistic.
It's equal to 4av over n0.
And when this is greater than
or equal the log of the
threshold, you go this way.
When it's less than,
you go this way.
So when you then multiply by n0
over 4a, your decision rule
is you just look at
the observation.
You compare it with n0 times
log of eta divided by 4a.
And at this point we can go back
to this picture and sort
of sort out what all
of it means.
Because this point here
is now the threshold.
It's n0 times log of
eta divided 4eta.
By 4a.
That's what we said the
threshold had to be.
So we have these two Gaussian
curves now.
Why do we have to go back and
look at these Gaussian curves?
I told you that once we
calculated the likelihood
ratio we could forget
about the curves.
So why do I want to put
the curves back in?
Well because I want to calculate
the probability of
error at this point.
OK?
And it's easier to calculate the
probability of error if,
in fact, I draw curve for
myself and I look at
what's going on.
So here's the threshold.
Here's the density when H equals
one is the correct
hypothesis.
The probability of error is the
probability that when I
send one, the observation is
going to be a random variable
with this probability density
and if it's a wild case, and I
got an enormous value of noise,
positive noise, the
noise is going to push me over
that threshold there and I'm
going to make a mistake.
So, in fact, the probability
of error-- conditional on
sending one--
is just this probability of that
little space in there.
OK?
Which is the probability that
I'm going to say that zero
occurred when, in fact,
one occurred.
So that's my probability of
error when one occurs.
What's the probability of
error when zero occurs?
Well it's the same analysis.
When zero occurs--
mainly when the correct
hypothesis is zero--
the output, v, follows this
probability density here.
And I'm going to screw up if
the noise carries me beyond
this point here.
So you can see what the
threshold is doing now.
I mean, when you choose a
threshold which is positive it
makes it much harder to screw
up when you send a minus a.
It makes it much easier
to screw up when
you send a plus a.
But you see that's what we
wanted to do, because the
threshold was positive in this
case, because p1 was so much
larger than p0.
And because p1 is so much
larger than p0--
p1 happens almost
all the time--
and therefore you would normally
almost choose p1
without looking at v. Which says
you want to push it over
that way a little bit.
OK, when you calculate this
probability of error, it's the
probability of the tail of a
Gaussian random variable.
So you define this tail
variable, q of x, is the
complimentary distribution
function of a
normal random variable.
It's the integral from x to
infinity of one over the
square root of 2pi, e to the
minus c squared over 2.
I guess this would make better
sense if this were a z--
one and--
oh, no.
No, I did it right
the first time.
That's an x, because x is the
limit in there, you see.
So I'm calculating all of the
probability density that's off
to the right of x.
And the probability of error
when H is equal to one is this
probability-- which looks like
it's the tail on the negative
side but if you think about
it a little bit, since the
Gaussian curve is symmetric, you
can also look at it as a q
function where now when you have
this is equal to zero,
this corresponds to changing
this plus to a minus here and
that's the only change.
OK, so this looks a
little ugly and it
looks a little strange.
I mean you can sort
of interpret
this part of it here--
I can interpret this
part if I'm using
maximum likelihood decoding--
maximum likelihood is mapped
decoding where the threshold
is equal to one.
In other words, it's where
you're assuming that the
hypothesis is equally likely to
be zero or one-- a priori--
which is a good assumption
almost always in communication
because we work very hard in
doing source coding to make
those binary digits equally
likely zero or one.
And there are other reasons
for choosing maximum
likelihood.
If you don't know anything about
the probabilities it's a
good assumption in a sort
of a max/min sense.
It sort of limits how much you
can screw up by having the
wrong probability, so it's a
very robust choice also.
OK, but now this, we're taking
the ratio of a with the square
root of n0.
Well the square root of n0 over
2 is really the standard
deviation of the noise.
So what we're doing is comparing
the amount of input
we've put in with the standard
deviation of the noise.
Now does that make any sense?
The probability of error
depends on that ratio?
Well yeah, it makes a
whole lot of sense.
Because if, for example, I
wanted to look at this problem
in a different scaling
system--
if this is volts and I want to
look at it in milli-volts--
I'm going to divide a by, I'm
going to multiply a by 1000.
I'm going to multiply the
standard deviation of the
noise by 1000.
Because one of the things we
always do here-- the way we
choose n0 over 2--
n0 over 2 is sort of a
meaningless quantity.
It's the noise energy in one
degree of freedom in the
scaling reference that we're
using for the data.
OK?
And that's the only definition
you can come up with that
makes any sense.
I mean you scale the data in
whatever way you please, and
when we've gone from baseband
to passband, we in fact have
multiplied the energy in the
input by a factor of two.
And therefore, because of
that, we're going to--
n0 at passband is going to be a
square root of 2 bigger than
it is at baseband.
If you don't like that,
live with it.
That's the way it is.
Nobody will change n0,
no matter who wants
them to change it.
OK, so this term make sense.
It's the ratio of the signal
amplitude to the standard
deviation of the noise.
And that should be the only way
that the signal amplitude
or the standard deviation of the
noise enters in, because
it's really the ratio that
has to be important.
Why this crazy term?
Well if you look at the curve
you can sort of see why it is.
The threshold test is comparing
the likelihood ratio
of this curve with
the likelihood
ratio of this curve.
What's going to happen as
a gets very, very large?
You move a out, and the thing
that's happening then is this
curve-- which is now coming down
in a modest way here-- if
you move a way out here, you're
going to have almost
nothing there.
And it's going to be going
down very fast.
It's going to be going
down very fast
relative to its magnitude.
In other words the bigger
a gets, the bigger this
difference is going to be
for any given threshold.
And that's why you get a over
square root of n0 here.
And here you get exactly
the opposite thing.
That's because for a given
threshold, as this signal to
noise ratio gets bigger, this
threshold term becomes almost
totally unimportant.
I mean you get so much
information out of the reading
you're making, because it's
so reliable, that having a
threshold is almost completely
irrelevant.
And therefore you can sort
of forget about it.
If a is very large, this
term is zilch.
OK?
So if you want to have reliable
communication and you
use a large amount of single
noise ratio to get it, that's
another reason for forgetting
about whether the threshold is
one or something else.
And we would certainly like to
deal with problems where the
threshold is equal to one
because most people who
remember q of a signal
to noise ratio.
I don't know anybody who can
remember this formula.
I'm sure there's some people,
but I don't think anybody who
works in the communication
field ever thinks
about this at all.
Except the first time they
derive it and the say, "Oh,
that's very nice." And then they
promptly forget about it.
The only reason I think
about it more is I
teach the course sometimes.
Otherwise I would forget
about it, too.
OK, which is what this says.
For communication we assume
p0 is equal to p1.
So we assume that eta
is equal to one.
So the probability of error,
which is also the probability
of error when H is equal to
one-- in other words when a
one actually enters the
communication system-- is
equal to the probability of
error when H is equal to 0.
In other words these two tails
here, when the threshold is
equal to one you set the
threshold right there.
The probability of this tail
is clearly equal to the
probability of this tail.
Just by symmetry.
So these two error probabilities
are the same.
And in fact they are just
q of a over the square
root of n0 over 2.
It's nice to put this
in terms of energy.
We said before that energy is
sort of important in the
communication field.
So we call e sub b the energy
per bit that we're
spending to send data.
I mean don't worry about the
fact that we're only sending
one bit and then we're tearing
the communication system down.
Because pretty soon we're going
to send multiple bits.
But the amount of energy we're
spending sending this one bit
is a squared.
At least back in this frame of
reference that we're looking
at now, where we're just looking
at this discrete
signal and single
variable noise.
And n0 over 2 is the noise
variance of this particular
random variable, z, so when we
write this out in terms of Eb,
which is a squared, it looks
like this-- it's 2eb over n0.
So the probability of error for
this binary communication
problem is just the square
root of 2Eb over n0.
Which is a formula that
you want to remember.
It's the error probability for
binary detection when n0 over
2 is the noise energy on this
one degree of freedom and Eb
is the amount of energy you're
spending on this
one degree of freedom.
You will see about
50 variations of
this as we go on.
If you try to remember this
fundamental definition, it'll
save you a lot of agony.
Even so, everybody I know who
deals with this kind of thing
always screws up the
factors of twos.
And finally when they get all
done, they try to figure out
from common sense or from
something else, what the
factors of two ought to be.
And they reduce their
probability of error to about
a quarter after they're all done
with doing all of that.
OK, so we spent a lot
of time analyzing
binary antipodal signals.
What about the binary non
antipodal signals?
This is beautiful example of
Shannon's idea of studying the
simplest cases first.
If you have two signals, one of
which is b and one of which
is b prime, and they can be put
anywhere on the real line.
And what I've done, because I
didn't want to plot this whole
picture again, is I just took
the zero out, and I replaced
the zero by the point halfway
between these two points which
is b plus b prime over 2.
And then we look at it and we
say what happens if you have
an arbitrary set of two points
anywhere on the real line?
Well when I send this point the
likelihood, conditional on
this point being sent, is
this Gaussian curve
centered on b prime.
When I send b the likelihood
is a Gaussian
curve centered on b.
And it is in fact the same curve
that we drew before.
If in fact I replaced zero with
a center point between
these two, which is b
plus b prime over 2.
And if I then define a as this
distance in here, the
probability of error that I
calculated before is the same
as it was before.
Now I would suggest to all of
you that you try to find the
probability of error for this
system here, just not using
what we've already done, and
just writing out the
likelihood ratios as a function
of an arbitrary b
prime and an arbitrary b and
finding a likelihood ratio,
and calculating through
all of that.
And most of you are capable of
calculating through all of it.
But when you do so, you will
get a god awful looking
formula, which just looks
totally messy.
And by looking at the formula
you are not going to be able
to realize that what's going
on is what we see here from
the picture.
And the only reason we figured
out what was going like the
picture is we already
solved the problem
for the Simpson case.
OK so it never makes any sense
in this problem to look at
this general case.
You always want to say the
general case is just a special
case of a special case.
Where you just have to define
things slightly differently.
OK, so we're going to do the
center point, then, I mean it
might be a pilot tone.
It might be any other non
information bearing signal.
In other words were sending
the one bit.
Sometimes for some reason or
other, you need to get
synchronization.
You need to get other things
in a communication system.
And for that reason, you
send other things.
We'll talk about a lot
of those later.
But they don't change the error
probability at all.
The error probability is
determined solely by the
distance between these two
points which we call 2a.
So probability of error remains
the same in terms of
this distance.
The energy per bit
now changes.
The energy per bit is
the energy here
plus the energy here.
Which in fact is the energy
in the center
point plus a squared.
I mean we've done that in a
number of contexts, the way to
find the energy in a binary
random variable is to take the
energy in the center point
plus the energy in the
difference.
It's the same as finding the
fluctuation plus the
square of the mean.
It's that same underlying
idea.
So any time you use non
antipodal and you shift things
off the mean, you can
see what's going
on very, very easily.
You waste energy.
I mean it might not be wasted,
you might have to waste it for
some reason.
But as far as a communication
is concerned you're simply
wasting it.
So your energy per bit changes,
but your probability
of error remains the same.
Because of that, you get a very
clear cut idea of what
it's costing you to send
that pilot tone.
Because in fact what you've done
is to just increase this
energy, which we talk about
in terms of db.
If c is equal to a in this case
which, as will see, is a
common thing that happens in a
lot of systems, what you've
lost is a factor three db.
Because you're using twice as
much energy which is three db
more energy, than you have
to use for the pure
communication.
So it's costing you three db to
do whatever silly thing you
want to do for synchronization
or something else.
Which is why people work very
hard to try to send signals
which carry their own
synchronization
information in them.
And we will talk about that more
when we get to wireless
and things like that.
OK.
Let's go on to real antipodal
vectors in
white Gaussian noise.
And again, let me point out to
you again that one of the
remarkable things about
detection theory is once you
understand detection for
antipodal binary signals and
Gaussian noise, everything
else just follows along.
OK, so here what we're going to
do is to assume that under
the hypothesis H equals zero--
in other words conditional on
a zero entering the
communication system--
what we're going to send is not
a single degree, is not
something in a single
degree of freedom.
But we're actually going
to send a vector.
And you can think of that if you
want to as sending a way
form and breaking up the
waveform into an orthonormal
expansion and a1 to
ak as being the
coefficients in that expansion.
So we're going to use
several degrees of
freedom to send one signal.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I'm only
sending one bit.
And on Wednesday I'm going to
talk about what happens when
we want to send multiple bits
or when we want to send a
large number of signals in one
degree of freedom, or all
those cases, multiple
hypotheses.
You know what's going
to happen?
It's going to turn out to be
a trivial problem again.
Multiple hypotheses are no
harder than just binary
hypotheses.
So again, once you understand
the simplest case, all
Gaussian problems turn
out to be solved.
Just with minor variations
and minor tweaks.
OK, so I have antipodal
vectors.
One vector is a1 to a sub k.
Under the other hypothesis we're
going to send minus a,
which is the opposite vector.
So if we're dealing with two
dimensional space with
coordinates here and here,
if I send this I'm
going to send this.
If I send that I'm going to
send that, and so forth.
As the opposite alternative.
The likelihood ratio is then,
the probability of vector v
conditional on sending this.
I'm assuming here that the noise
is IID and each noise
variable has mean zero and
variance n0 over 2.
Namely, we're pretending we're
communication people here,
using and n0 over 2 here.
So the conditional density--
the likelihood of this output
vector given zero-- is just
this density of z shifted
over by a.
So it's what we've talked about
as the Gaussian density.
Just this, which is just the
energy in v minus a is what
that turns out to be.
So the log likelihood ratio is
the ratio of this quantity to
the density where H
is equal to one.
And when H is equal to one, what
happens is the same thing
as happened before.
One makes this sign turn
into a plus sign.
So when I look at the log
likelihood ratio, I want to
take the ratio of this quantity
to the same quantity
with a plus put into it.
And when I take the log of that,
what happens is I get
this term minus the opposite
term of the opposite side.
So I have minus the norm squared
of v minus a plus the
norm squared of v
plus a over n0.
And again, if you multiply
this out, the v squareds
cancel out.
The a squareds cancel out.
And you just get the inner
product terms.
And strangely enough you get the
same formula that you got
before, almost, except here you
have the inner product of
v with a instead of just the
product of v times a.
So in fact we just have a slight
generalization of the
thing that we did before.
In other words, the
scalar product is
a sufficient statistic.
Now what does that tell you?
It tells you how to
build a detector.
OK?
It tells you when you have a
vector detection problem, the
thing that you want to do is to
take this vector, v, that
you have and form the inner
product of v times a.
If in fact v is a waveform
and a is a waveform,
what do you do then?
Well the first thing you
do is to think of
v as being a vector--
where it's the vector of
coefficients-- in the
expansion for that waveform
and a in the same way.
You look at what the inner
product is then, and then you
say, "well what does that
correspond to when I deal with
L2 waveforms?" What's the inner
product for L2 waveforms?
It's the integral of the product
of the waveforms.
And how do you form the
integral of the
product of the waveforms?
You take this waveform here.
You turn it around and you call
it a matched filter to a.
And you take the received
waveform.
You pass it through the max
filter for a, and you look at
the output for it.
Now, let's go back and look at
what all of this was doing.
And for now let's forget
about the baseband to
the passband business.
Let's just look at this part
here because it's a little
easier to see this first.
So this comes in here.
Now remember what
we were saying
when we studied Nyquist.
We said a neat thing to do was
to use a square root of the
Nyquist pulse at the
transmitter.
When you use a square root of
the Nyquist pulse at the
transmitter, what you have is
orthogonality between the
pulse and all of its shifts.
Well now we don't much care
about the orthogonality
between the pulse and all of the
shifts because we're only
sending this one bit anyway.
But it sort of looks like we're
going to be able to put
that back in in a nice
convenient way.
So we're sending this one pulse,
p of t, city and what
did we do in this baseband
demodulator?
We passed this through another
filter, q of t, which was the
matched filter to p of t.
What's our optimal detector
for maximum likelihood?
It's to take whatever this
waveform was, pass it through
the matched filter.
In other words, to calculate
that inner product we just
talked about.
OK?
So in fact when we were looking
at the Nyquist problem
and worrying about inner symbol
interference, in fact
what we were doing was also
doing the first part of an
optimal MAP detector.
And at this point what comes
out of here is a single
number, v, which in fact now is
the inner product of this
waveform at this point.
With the waveform,
a, that we sent.
OK?
In other words, we started out
by saying, "let's suppose that
what we have here is a number.
What's the optimal detector to
build?" And then we go on and
say, "OK, let's suppose we
look at the problem here.
What's the optimal detector to
build now?" And the optimal
detector to build now at this
point is this matched filter
to this input waveform.
Followed by the inner product
here-- which is what the match
filter does for us-- followed
by our binary antipodal
detector again.
OK?
So by studying the problem at
this point, we now understand
what happens at this point.
And do I have time to show you
what happens at this point?
I don't know.
Let me--
let's not do that at
least right now--
let's look at the picture of
this that we get when we just
look at the problem when
we have two dimensions.
So we're either going to
transmit a vector, a, or we're
going to transmit a
vector, minus a.
And think of this in
two dimensions.
When we transmit the
vector, a, we have
two dimensional noise.
We've already pointed out that
two dimensional Gaussian noise
has circular symmetry.
Spherical symmetry in an
arbitrary number of dimension.
So what happens is you get
these equal probability
regions which are spreading out
like when you drop a rock
into a pool of water.
You see all of these things
spreading out in circles.
And you then say, "OK, what's
this inner product going to
correspond to?" Finding the
inner product and comparing it
with a threshold.
Well you can see geometrically
what's going to happen here.
You're trying to do maximum
likelihood.
And we already know we're
supposed to calculate the
inner product, so what the inner
product is going to do
is take whatever v that we
receive-- it's going to
project it on to this line
between 0 and a.
So if I got a v here I'm going
to project it down to here.
And then what I'm going to do
is I'm going to compare the
distance from here to there
with the distance
from here to there.
Which says first project, then
do the old decision in a one
dimensional way.
Now geometrically, this distance
squared is equal to
this distance squared plus
this distance squared.
And this distance squared is
equal to the same distance
squared plus this distance
squared.
So whatever you decide to do in
terms of these distances,
you will also decide to do in
terms of these distances.
Which also means that the
maximum likelihood regions
that you're going to develop,
or in fact the maximum a
posteriori probability regions
are simply planes.
Which are perpendicular
to the line between
minus a and plus a.
OK?
So if you're doing maximum
likelihood you just form a
plane halfway between
these two points.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: We got the error
probability just by first
doing the projection and then
turning it into this scale or
problem again.
So in fact the error
probability--
What?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The probability of
error is just the probability
of error in the projection.
Did I write it down someplace?
Oh yeah, I did write it down.
But I wrote it down, well
I sort of cheated.
It's in the notes.
I mean the likelihood ratio is
just a center product here
which is a number.
And when you find the error
probability, you just use the
same q formula that
we used before.
And in place of a
you substitute--
in place of a you substitute the
inner product of v with a.
Which is the corresponding
quantity.
So it's q of 4va
divided by n0.
OK?
So that's the maximum likelihood
error probability.
OK?
In other words, nothing
new has happened here.
You just go through the match
filter and then you do this
same one dimensional problem
that we've already
figured out how to do.
I think I'm going to stop there
and we'll do the complex
case which really corresponds to
what happens after baseband
to passband then passband
to baseband.